[Music]
we probably agree about a lot but I just
to be fun I'll I'll disagree wow demon
just for the sake of being combative oh
God are you feeling Punchy today a
little Punchy okay so first statement is
you should tell someone if they have bad
breath
thank you
I you've just gotta you shouldn't say
you have bad breath you just hand them a
little list you're a piece of gum just a
Cuba gum and or you take one out
pretending you need some and then you
kind of casually go hey would you like
one yeah yeah I I strongly agree with
that I totally agree have you had ever
had it when you're just like oh God I
can't stand it yes like you know when
you when you do like intimate scenes
yeah yeah is
etiquette and you've got to brush your
teeth I agree use some mouthwash
strongly agree stick some gum on the
roof of your mouth yes and then we can
kiss it's for me it's less the co-star
that you're kissing who you're probably
going to be friends with anyway and I
can forgive some halitosis I had to kiss
uh Scarlet had to kiss Scarlett
Johansson can you imagine how horrible
that was imagine how awful that was what
we did such a shame this was really such
terrible lips and everything it must
have been so awful it was hell okay
first of all
she was mean and then no what happened
was we did a shot before lunch and it
was like this nice little two shot that
ended in the kiss and it was really good
and we went to lunch and she and I both
thought it was over and she had some
garlic she ate like an onion sandwich
and she came in and Cameron Crowe had
set the camera up and it was like a
tight shot of the kiss and she goes oh
I literally just had I had like an onion
sandwich that's how we did this but were
you still sort of slightly aroused
getting to do that with her or not no I
was making fun of her the entire time
about her onion breath which I didn't
even smell perfect because her breath
smells like roses
Jimmy Fallon is a better talk show host
than Jimmy Kimmel obviously obviously
all day long Jimmy Kimmel
wow
I think there's a little bit of
bitterness right what is it about Fallon
that you love
well you know it's kind of like the uh
the enemy of my enemy is my friend yes
you know yeah of course
um but yeah Jimmy's incredibly Fallon is
incredibly talented Fallon is incredible
I have to fight for Kimmel though
because he used to be my neighbor so I I
mean I would get in trouble I'm very
close with his wife and you know he's
never let me on his show you realize
that ever I know 17 years no it's okay
okay you've had plenty of other torches
like Jimmy Fallon who I also adore yeah
and love
and love yeah so it's just very
difficult very difficult question my
opinion of him slightly softened when I
heard that he was paying his entire
staff through the writer's strike so
nice so I
I just hate him so much
I'll go like that okay fine I like that
I like that British food is better than
American food
wow yeah have you ever had a lovely
roast a Sunday roast do you know you're
known for having horrible food it's like
a thing do you know what I don't like
eating what cheeseburgers and Nuggets
okay that's all we have in America you
know what's great about America what we
are a Melting Pot of all the other
countries so all their best do you know
that do you know what the number one
most eaten food in England is would you
like to know what it is
would you agree to know what it is
it's a chicken tikka masala
how cultural is that next question award
shows should have a 20 second limit on
all speeches
like out the window
yes less do you know do you remember
when Garrison he's got it no I already
got up there anyway thank you so much
and he left and people were delighted no
you know who Joe Pesci when Joe Pesci
what did he says he just went very
honored
sleeping on your own is better than
sleeping next to a partner
oh well wow so you see you know you're
going to get in trouble if like no but
what's interesting is my partner would
put that over there because I've been I
snore oh
or and it drives her crazy and
she's like yeah we might she she's like
you know the I'm actually gonna go there
because I don't I'm not married to a
Sonora yeah it's always better when
you're sleeping
do you sleep sort of intertwined
no since I broke my collarbone like 10
years ago I gotta I gotta sleep with
like Matt got briefly into cycling or
like proper cycle like with the kit the
like a mammal Middle Ages you got the
whole kit didn't you you got the life
deal mountain biking so but it's never
been quite right so I gotta kind of I
gotta if it'll wake me up if I don't I
gotta get a pillow under it it's the
whole thing
ancient old man Island you should clap
when the plane lands to say thanks to
the pilot or just with relief
oh wow
do your job like relief no no I clap I
agree you should clap you should clap it
out now if there's inclement weather and
I have been in some of these I strongly
agree you give that man or woman that
drops when they when we landed in Paris
that was bumpy yeah didn't love it no
yeah didn't love it everyone went very
quiet yeah you guys must fly a lot as
well so that's why a lot we go on
vacation together yeah yeah too much is
it like a yearly thing just go to the
same place or no I don't I just try to
go on their vacations I did not get the
invite to Mykonos this year oh just a
little bit no disappointed maybe next
year you'll be on the invite I'll put
you on the list fingers crossed
like how connotations but
it's a makeup
trip I didn't get the invite last year
you didn't well I did but I got a job
and so I was working so everyone went to
Mykonos without me oh you see they sent
me all the pictures every day and you
got super jelly yeah we all went back
McDonald's breakfast should be available
all day every day of course it should
and it is in Australia
is it yeah yeah fun fact
I'm not like a massive fan of the Egg
McMuffin so it's not something I sort of
Need for 24 hours a day you don't want a
pancake at four in the afternoon I don't
know okay no all right that's good to
know do you have a McDonald's order do
you have McDonald's is it I go to the
number one value meal with the diet coke
no no no value like the Big Mac with the
fries yeah I would I would take down a
double cheeseburger quite happily I mean
maybe even though if you're gonna do a
double cheeseburger why not get the
special sauce lettuce cheese pickles on
your own sesame seed bun
you already got the two all beef patties
you know what I'm saying this is
impressive the person opposite me is a
joy to work with
if you I thought you were gonna go
no I beat you to that one that way I
know because I was with I was like is he
gonna do a joking one okay I strongly
agree I've worked I don't joke about
that Emily
[Laughter]
did you know
someone said I loved you in the
attachment Bureau
that's how well known the film is yes it
lasted it loved it lasted
but thank you so much thank you thank
you very much this was a lot of fun
Oppenheimer is the best movie being
released this week
sorry I haven't I don't know what else
is coming out and it's
so weird that we have to be in bed
number he waits until he thinks I'm
asleep and then he throws bunny out of
bed no yeah and I get so mad I'm like
everybody out of bed